this right here is what I believe to be
the best charging station in the world
since wasn't sponsored by ESR in fact
it's the world's first Apple Certified
Six in One Max save charger with Gan
technology and if you don't know what
that means I'll explain why it's so
important in this video now what makes
this macsafe charger so special is that
it not only supports Apple's official
made for iPhone and made for Apple watch
charging specs meaning a full 15 watts
for the iPhone just like Apple's own Max
save Puck but it also supports full 5
watt charging for the Apple watch which
is actually the peak charging speed for
the new Apple watch Ultra so you're
getting the fastest charging speeds
possible all around and even better the
max save charger features cryo boost
cooling technology which basically helps
keep your iPhone cool while charging
which Believe It or Not makes the
charging speed even faster than Apple's
own Max save pug which I'll show you
later in this video now you might have
seen our testing of esr's Three in One
Max save charging stand from a few
months ago which we called the best
value Max save charger because of its
cryo boost technology but this new six
in one stand is better in every single
way the previous one was limited to 7.5
Watts Max life iPhone charging while
this one gets the full 15 watts and the
previous one also required you to use
your own Apple watch charger that you
would route through the stand it also
came with an external power supply
connected to a wall outlet which this
new one doesn't by using a new
technology that I'll explain in a minute
and of course one of the most unique
things about this new charger is that
it's a six in one which basically means
you can charge all of your devices at
once so you've got your iPhone charging
at full 15 watt speed then you have have
your Apple watch charging at full speed
your set of airpods which by the way
snap into place magnetically and then an
additional three ports on the side
including two USBC ports each up to 100
watts of power so you can actually fast
charge your MacBook from those ports and
finally a 5 watt USB a port totaling six
devices you can charge at once now that
right there is really special and unique
just imagine plugging in six Apple
devices at night and waking up to full
batteries on all of them using just a
single wall plug connector with no huge
charger sticking out of it because the
power adapter is actually built into the
design of this charger and to be
completely honest it's really surprising
that they fit that much Tech including a
huge 100 watt power supply into this
compact charging station that can charge
six devices especially seeing as their
apple certified Chargers and the secret
behind that is esr's cutting edge Gan
technology which stands for gallium
nitride components which are Ultra
efficient and Compact and the most
important part is that it automatically
adjusts the power allocation of that 100
watts to assure maximum charging speeds
for every device so for example if
you're fast charging your MacBook and
then you connect your iPhone it'll make
sure to allocate 15 watts of fast
charging to the iPhone and then same
thing for the Apple watch with 5 Watts
now before we get into covering the very
fast charging speeds with their cryo
boost fan technology I want to talk
about this design I love how there's a
two-tone white and silver metal finish
that reminds me of Apple's silver iPhone
14 pro which looks incredible and the
whole thing feels very solid and high
quality especially with the aluminum
alloy support brackets for the iPhone
and Apple watch Chargers the size and
weight is really impressive for how much
Tech is packed into here and I love how
they went for a minimalistic and clean
look I also like how the Apple watch
charging puck comes in from the side so
that you can easily slide on your Apple
watch which is useful for these Metal
Solid bands like the one I have right
here for my ultra making it convenient
to grab and go I also like how the
macsafe charging stand section is angled
towards you so it's perfect for sitting
at your desk leaving your iPhone ready
in case you get some notifications texts
or calls coming through and since it's
got extra room around it you can easily
spin your iPhone horizontally to take
advantage of the new nightstand mode for
charging at night and yes while this
charging station does feature lights as
you can see right here you can easily
turn them off by pressing this little
button at the base of the stand so you
can fall fast asleep and yes it does
completely shut off with no lights at
all and then during the daytime you can
also use your iPhone horizontally to
watch videos or movies when at your desk
all while fast charging the battery and
speaking of exactly that when you're in
this video watching scenario and
charging your iPhone this ESR Max save
charger can actually charge your iPhone
over two times faster than the official
Max save charger and it all comes down
to their cryo boost technology the
reason that's important is because fast
charging at 15 watts adds a lot of heat
to your iPhone so what Apple's Puck does
is it slows down the charging wattage to
keep the temperature cool to protect
your iPhone's battery health so the goal
of the ESR cryo boost is to cool it down
while charging so the temps never even
heat up enough to trigger the iPhone to
slow down the charging speed and
therefore you get much faster charging
than you would with Apple's own 15 watt
official magsafe Puck and on top of that
it also protects your iPhone's battery
health this effect is is Amplified even
further if you're actually using your
iPhone while charging like let's say
watching a video at the same time which
actually causes a lot of extra heat from
the display being on and the active
processing as well which is where esr's
cryo boost technology really shines
looking at this chart comparing this
charging station to some other options
including Apple's own Max save charger
you can see that Apple's official
charger really slows down because of the
extra heat from watching the video but
this ESR charger finishes over two times
faster because it's actively cooling
down the iPhone and allowing for faster
charging so with that said you really
can't beat this charger since it ensures
the fastest possible charging speed at
all times regardless of whether you're
using it at night or while watching
videos and even better the integrated
Apple watch charger also supports the
fastest 5 watt charging speed you can
get which is very unique since many of
other chargers don't have both official
chargers at the same time and then
adding to that you also get another
magnetic charging pad dedicated to your
airpods and finally three extra ports
for flexibility so you can charge
additional devices and I love how they
made each USBC Port able to support up
to 100 watts of charging which is fast
enough for fast charging your MacBook or
splitting that 100 Watts up between six
devices to fast charge them all at once
and now let's finally get into the price
of esr's six on one charger starting
with a value breakdown since you're
getting official certified 15 watt Max
safe and 5 watt Apple watch charging
speeds this thing essentially replaces
Apple's macsafe charger for 39 their
magnetic Apple watch fast charger for 29
and their dual 35 watt USBC power
adapter for fifty nine dollars to charge
both of them which is a total of a
hundred twenty seven dollars but then
that's still missing a wireless charger
for the airpods which is at least
another 30 bucks and we're not even
including a hundred watts of fast
charging for a Macbook which if we take
the closest power adapter option from
Apple would cost another seventy nine
dollars and don't forget that it comes
with two more ports for charging other
devices as well so we're looking at well
over 200 of Apple charging accessories
just to match what esr's six in one
power station can do and keep in mind
that none of those Apple accessories can
replicate the cryo boost cooling
technology which greatly improves
charging speed and the good news is that
you can get it on Kickstarter with their
super early bird special starting today
for only a hundred and forty three
dollars using the links below for the
first 400 orders making it the best
value Apple charging station ever made
being able to charge your entire Apple
ecosystem of devices while using just
one power plug and to think all of it is
packed into this compact design which is
incredibly impressive and this version
I'm reviewing is a prototype and the
final version will have all the little
details even more polished there is also
a link to esr's Mac safe lineup of
products for other areas of your life
like from home to work to travel such as
the ESR magsafe wallet maxsafe charger
power bank and more and you could also
search ESR Max safe on Amazon so don't
forget to check out the link below to
order today so you don't miss out on the
limited quantity of super early bird
pricing let me know your thoughts on
this charging station down in the
comment section below and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign